come to set with me today we're at
buzzfeed tasty and we've got a long day
ahead of us so buckle up kicking it off
with an iced cappuccino people tell me
that's not a real drink but i am
drinking it so how do you explain that
today we're making a classic top down
tasty video haven't done this in a while
i'm a little rusty i have to do an apron
check and i'm already a mess went to the
bathroom and realized i look like an
inmate at the county jail oh well on to
set number two we're grilling outside
it's 90 degrees so i'm already sweating
in my jail suit but the way i put that
kebab on the grill art time to play a
little cornhole while they finish up the
beauty shots and i just would like
everyone to know that i did not start
this fire
on purpose i am not used to long shoot
days anymore so i got a little tired but
it's time for our third and final set of
the day which i happen to perfectly
match i practiced my lines and then got
mic'd up side note i am notorious for
wearing the worst outfits to get mic'd
up in but i barely need a mic anyways
i'm so loud i got to bring in some
friends for a taste test here's nathan
pretending he didn't like it but it was
delicious and that's a wrap time for a
nap